yeah welcome to this video playing eerie
kofsky from Spain I guess and we get
green felt all yep and I Kings Indian da
play this h4 line yeah the service has
really taken off lately as a popular
reply again to this opening Queen a5
inserts the move Queen a 5 there are
take 135 now aseem playing is he taking
d5 maybe 1 94 95 I i had an applet scam
recently in a rapid game on the SEC 15
minute game and I actually thought that
this is quite um quite nice for for
white
why does yeah why does an excellent
shape here okay okay King takes yeah why
not so night a six is he winning the
spawn back by force hmm i can i can play
play Brooksie one try to to keep that
for the moment
hey three that is a bit a bit risky
maybe yeah but anyway if if he doesn't
get it and I can play before this night
when a six is really am a silly piece
maybe you should be three at some some
point yeah this could be the the
solution 94
look the a tag 0 King c3 attacking the
the bishop twice intending to play
before I'd keep the keep this ball as
mentioned it's not just the part it's
the fact that this night is in such a
ridiculous position which makes this
interesting i think it's just good for
for white what what can I say Knight f3
just back probably yeah it's a temple
yeah I can I could even take you five
now but I want to get some stuff out he
needs to spend or it doesn't and I
thought you need to spend a move to to
cover you five okay it's a it's a thing
it's a central pawn and for those miles
suffering is is it's okay in five maybe
f3e for an ID f6 threatening and
attending a 493
yeah I don't think he's got enough
compensation okay giving giving up the
piece don't really believe in it I can I
can yeah okay it's 95 m 95
hmm he's got at least a boatload of
checks now 95 or taking 95 yeah yeah
yeah this is so this is is interesting
actually
okay let's go here need to get get
developed in well now i can play net 93
is playing night f4 okay but what else
are playing mmm this is really good
seems it seems that wave might have 4k
money to drop back then
I take night takes and truck you one
lady yeah it's not it's not too much fun
it's very active
yeah even taking on t1.id rupee fibers
not easy at all covering a two
yeah one problem of all this is not in
this is counter players can easily even
lead to a loss with all this activity
it's not like you it's just um trying to
hang on and try to draw weight t7 I
should grab this chance I think okay
should I check on b7 even on night what
about night geez II 45 yeah this is good
threatening mate Oh didn't see that geez
ah did I screw this up sometimes time
warning
don't ever move Jesus check check check
check
check no yeah only had 44 seconds ah
talk about the silliness really screwed
this up that name he had some serious
counter play but around here white is
just flat-out winning completely winning
yeah plus seven yeah this is of course
even right and now not f6 is a force
made even I really just forgot that you
can take it there's a forcemeat night
eight rook h7 mate 94 maiden six moves
but okay I just forgot that you can take
even that didn't he take I can still
let's rook h1 mate I am such an idiot or
sometimes it really hurts Knight f3 em
and bend over yeah just made yeah he
does he has no no way to defend it I can
go here and that's just this oh what a
silly nose gifting away this point yeah
well thanks for watching